welcome to the reason live stream which
is pre-taped today because of some
scheduling issues I am Zach Weissmuller
joined by my colleague Nick Gillespie
and Ian Vasquez vice president for
international studies at the Cato
Institute and one of the co-authors of
the 2022 human Freedom index a joint
effort put out annually by the Cato and
Frazier Institutes today we're talking
about the state of human freedom in this
post-covered world and part of the
reason we're talking about that is
because President Joe Biden has
officially ended the National Emergency
around covet
a lot of us thought it had been over for
a while but I guess it's official now uh
but before we get into that let's have a
flashback to a little over three years
ago when Trump first declared the
National Emergency in March 2020.
to unleash the full power of the federal
government did this effort today I am
officially declaring a national
emergency
two very big words
the action I am taking will open up
access to up to 50 billion dollars of
very importantly very important and a
large amount of money for States and
territories or localities and our shared
fight against
this disease
okay so and now we're doing quite little
Fanfare this uh the White House
announced the bill in a one sentence
statements saying HJ resolution 7 which
terminates the National Emergency
related to covid-19 pandemic has been
signed into law by the president
what's uh how are we all feeling about
the official end to the National
Emergency
Ian
well I think that as you said many of us
thought that that emergency ended a long
time ago so in a very very real sense I
think Biden is just catching up to the
rest of the country in this regard I
mean Most states moved on a long time
ago uh from the the restrictive measures
that that were imposed by them and
remember that most of the restrictive
measures were in the United States
imposed uh by the states and localities
and uh those have been long gone we've
had uh uh most Americans the vast
majority of them have immunity or have
been vaccinated so it doesn't pose the
threat that that it did early on when we
didn't have that kind of information so
this is uh uh long past due my uh my
main thoughts were you know when you
juxtapose Trump and then Biden we're
really going from strength to strength I
mean presidents right uh and I think
Pence might have been blinking in sos
message like a Vietnam pow in that in
that earlier clip uh to uh to uh follow
up on what Ian was saying you know it's
clear that in many profound ways uh the
states and localities certainly have
moved on not completely but fully I
think people have more but there's
always this question and I know we'll
talk about this later when you have
these massive events uh in this this we
could also be talking about the
financial crisis uh we could be talking
about 9 11 we could be talking about the
Red Scare in the 50s
um you you don't know fully like you
know the event is over and we seem to
have moved on but there's always these
weird kind of tendrils that continue
into the future
um and into the present that motivate a
lot of
um you know that motivate a lot of
policy or or attitudes
um that don't really become clear until
much later into the future and I worry
about that a lot
yeah and just uh at the state level here
this is a map of these states that still
have a public health emergency
declaration in place there's seven of
them one of them happens to be Texas
which uh might be surprising to hear but
when you dig into it it's because Texas
has the state of emergency in place so
that it can override local mask
restrictions and vaccine mandates and
and so forth so there's some still
hanging on I know my former State of
California just rescinded theirs uh a
couple weeks ago and now Gavin newsom's
doing a tour around the country to talk
about it but
um yeah this is uh the the end of an era
and I guess we'll see
as you're saying Nick what what lingers
and and that's kind of the the topic uh
for today because
um Ian is one of the co-authors of the
human Freedom index which but actually
before we get into that maybe you could
just explain to our audience what
exactly that is
sure the human Freedom index is a global
measurement of economic personal and
civil freedoms around the world and so
what we do is we take uh 83 distinct
measurements of freedom in areas ranging
from the rule of law or Safety and
Security or the size of government or
freedom of speech freedom of Association
12 big categories but 83 distinct
indicators for 165 countries and then we
put that data together to come up with
what we think is a reasonable picture of
Freedom human Freedom within countries
and at a global level and when we say
freedom we have an idea of what we mean
by that everybody has their own
definition of Freedom George Bush did
Hugo Chavez did Al-Qaeda did everybody
does we we by Freedom we mean the ABS
essence of coercive constraint the idea
that you can lead your life as you
choose as long as you respect the equal
rights of others and that's what we're
measuring and uh
and so it's really the first uh serious
systematic measurement of broad human
freedoms uh for a big set of countries
uh and the data that we're using spans
two decades now so it's very useful to
look at Trends and freedom as well Kim
before we go into what happened the most
recent version
um goes through year uh 2020 right
that's right I mean what one of the
things that that you find out when you
start working on international data is
that there's usually about a two-year
lag to be able to compare data and so
the latest data includes 2020 which of
course is the pandemic year
right and could you also because what
the first year that you published this
was what 2017 is that right so this is
that so this is their our eighth uh it
was 2015 but we've been adding data and
adding back years as data becomes
available as well so now we have two
decades of data can you just very
quickly say like going back 20 years
that uh to uh until 2020 and we're you
know we'll talk a lot about 2020 because
that's like you know a big year but uh
what you know is the Arc of Freedom
bending towards uh light or dark uh you
know up until 2020. what what was the
General trajectory so what we see is
with uh beginning in the year 2000 which
is the the year for which we have
complete data is uh human Freedom being
uh High relatively High certainly
compared to decades passed by what we
know uh right and continuing on an
upward trajectory up until the Year 2007
which is really the the global high
point of of human Freedom that coincides
with uh the financial Global financial
crisis which came the next year and we
see a steady decline of human Freedom uh
up through 2019 and of course the big
and then everything you know Freedom
breaks out everywhere right yeah and
then uh and then in 2000 in 2020 what we
see is that just the freedom falls off
of a cliff so you see the steady decline
in personal and economic freedoms
economic freedoms were fairly pronounced
and then you see this huge drop uh in
virtually every category of of Freedom
that you can think of in the year 2000
setting back to 2020 setting back uh the
world more than 20 years
what does that mean they're just like
you know the difference between say 7.3
and 7.0 can you you know is that the
difference between having a 95 and a 65
or is it the difference between you know
a 95 and I'm thinking of you know cool
tasks a 95 and a 90. it's a big it's a
big difference uh because
um you know the range of freedom in the
world we use a scale of zero to ten the
range of freedom in the world is not
zero to ten the range of freedom is
usually between four point something and
nine something like that and this is a
global average so it's taking into
account
um all North Korea and Switzerland right
we don't actually measure North Korea
because we can't the data doesn't exist
but but yes we're talking we're pretty
sure they're going to be in the bottom
they're going to be in the bottom half
except except that one of the things
that we noticed is that some of the
countries that were already low like
very low like Venezuela and so on they
were already pretty much rock bottom and
um they didn't there's not much more for
them to fall so the drops really were
coming from a lot of countries that were
relatively free I mean countries all
around the world saw drops but we saw
big drops in countries that uh are used
to a higher level of freedom and
typically we see from one year to the
next to the next is small movements in
Freedom in One Direction or another this
is a very large movement for the entire
world and can you it's a movement let me
just it's a movement that that affected
94 of the world's population wow so that
from 2007 to 2019 you already had
virtually 80 percent of the world's
population seeing some decline in
Freedom and then from 9 2019 to 20 94 of
the world's population saw this dramatic
decline can you put a little when you
talk about personal freedom uh what what
goes what are the the big parts of that
indicator is that you know kind of like
sexual freedom is it
um freedom of movement uh is it freedom
of expression what goes into that
category
we we have several several broad
categories that we measure one of them
is the rule of law so is there due
process uh do people get tortured when
when they're
um you know arrested or taken in by the
authorities another one is security and
safety if you live in a country where
you're likely to be disappeared or even
murdered on the street or or beaten up
your human freedom is not that high uh
and there's a big variance in the world
on on those indicators freedom of
movement is another one
um usually we haven't seen much in the
way of of movement from one year to the
next in that indicator of freedom of
movement but this this year we saw a
huge uh
uh movement for for obvious reasons but
what we're measuring there is freedom of
movement within countries and freedom of
movement between countries in the sense
of a country doesn't let you leave or it
doesn't let you come back uh to the
country and and of course in some
countries particularly uh the Middle
East and and North Africa this
particularly affects women in a way that
it doesn't affect men and by the way we
do have a measurement that takes into
account differences in treatment of
women and men on a lot of indicators in
this index we measure freedom of
religion and that's kind of
self-explanatory freedom of assembly
Association and what we call Civil
Society so freedom of assembly and
Association are are important but it's
also important to be able to set up a
civil society organization whether it's
the Garden Club or a political
discussion club and in a lot of
countries it's very difficult to do our
friends our libertarian friends in
France tell us that it's virtually
impossible to set up a Libertarian Think
Tank there it's very difficult and so we
find surprising things there freedom of
expression and information where we look
at all sorts of indicators you know the
ability to have access to the internet
or International uh information just
freedom of press Freedom that kind of
thing
and then what we call uh relationship uh
freedoms is
um uh same-sex our same-sex
relationships legal or illegal in a lot
of countries they still are illegal for
some in some cases it's just for men in
some cases it's for women some cases for
both what's the difference in treatment
of women during marriage or during or
after a divorce
um what what's the difference in their
relationship uh under the law with their
children those are the kinds of things
that that we measure that fall under the
category of
personal and civil freedoms so you just
laid out a the several different
categories of Freedom that you measured
that account for this giant drop off
that we see in this graph in 2020 could
you dig a little bit into what were some
of the policies worldwide that caused
this hit
um I've got I pulled a page from your
report here that shows some of these
different categories I mean we see the
the largest declines are in movement as
you uh alluded to earlier expression and
trade and even and religion is also on
there were there did you break down you
know specific policies that caused this
uh or was you know how much of a I guess
the quiet one question is how much of it
was policy and how much of it was just
kind of pure reaction to the pandemic
since we're talking about the pandemic
year here yeah that's a good question
because
um you might ask well some of this had
to take place as a response to the
pandemic even if it wasn't policy people
aren't going to be moving around and so
on but what we're measuring there are
restrictions and uh for the most part
that's what we're that's what we're for
the most part uh measuring and the chart
that you just showed shows a 20-year uh
movement of these indicators and
um and so freedom of movement I think
that was the one that saw the biggest
decline over that period but almost all
of that decline occurred in the year
2020 and for obvious reasons I mean you
remember we travel internationally came
to a halt travel locally in many places
came to all certainly in a lot of
countries you couldn't even leave your
house you could you know get in serious
trouble so that was a big a big hit
freedom of expression did too I mean
what you could say about the pandemic or
criticizing the government in many
countries rich countries and poor
countries democracies and
non-democracies
um was was restricted and what what
um
what media companies uh and even big
tech companies uh could say came under
scrutiny and under pressure
in a way that was probably already
happening but uh even more so because of
heightened pensions and health concerns
and so on freedom of Association we know
that people were not allowed to gather
this was a big a big issue and uh the
rule of law okay came under uh under
pressure and we see big Falls in that
because a lot of these things were uh
adapted or implemented in an arbitrary
way
favoring some uh groups and disfavoring
others in of course in the less free
countries in the authoritarian countries
this was done in the in a very random
way to go after uh dissidents or
political opponents and so on whereas in
more advanced countries
um there there may be other reasons for
that political reasons and maybe it was
more subtle but it still was happening
and that was denounced by human rights
groups including Human Rights Watch and
so on this was not just a problem for a
part of the world this is a pro this is
a problem that
um rich and poor countries democracies
and non-democracies uh were facing to
different differing degrees and you
talked about how I mean the real
drop-off came in more free countries if
you're in Venezuela you're already
pretty heavily restricted on a
day-to-day thing but I was thinking when
you were talking about like freedom of
assembly or whatnot I remember reasoning
running stories I think it was in
Mississippi of a church that was going
to have a drive-in you know religious
ceremony where people stayed in their
cars and parked in a lot you know and
and you know kind of you know didn't get
out of the car in a way it was you know
probably the best way to set up Church
in the future right you know where it's
like you don't even have to get out of
your car but they were banned from doing
that and that's like in the U.S that's
really up in a way that in a
country that is used to repression it's
like okay well that's just Sunday or
Saturday or whatever day we celebrate
Church on we're constrained
um
I think that's right and that that was
you know that kind of thing was the
probably among the most shocking for
Americans or for people who were used to
uh a good high degree of Freedom we
really haven't seen that kind of
curtailment of freedom to that degree
across such a wide uh number of freedoms
in the United States and and yeah you
have to go back to like World War II
really I mean probably where there was
rationing as well as uh curfews and you
know restrictions on on Industrial
inputs and things like that things were
actually being diverted away from you
know commercial activities into a war
effortably well that's right and that
you know not even during the financial
crisis did we see a drop in Freedom that
was this as as severe as this and um I
don't want to give the impression that
the that the less free more
authoritarian countries didn't see a big
drop in Freedom they did in fact
um we have a a chart in the book that
that looks at which are the countries
that most dropped in terms of freedom
from the high point in 2007 through 2020
and the top ten are all countries that
were led by authoritarian regimes but
what I want to emphasize there is that
that was an ongoing Trend and so what
the pandemic did was was accelerated
whereas in Liberal democracies and Freer
countries the trend was a slower Trend
and then there was a big drop off in one
year so that's probably the the the
difference in looking at one year to the
next versus uh what was going on and I
I mean it it's it's probably true to say
that the pandemic accelerated a number
of trends that were already happening in
the world including in in rich countries
I think that the
um
the freedom of speech issue which is
already coming under pressure in uh
liberal democracies
um came under more pressure and you know
Free Speech Advocates talk about a free
speech recession that had already been
going on in in the world and end
developing in developed countries and um
the pandemic accelerated that in rich
countries as well
when you talk about rule of law being a
major component of measuring freedom in
a country that was something that I
observed and I guess experienced
firsthand in a way I never had before
during this pandemic I was living in
California Los Angeles during the time
and it seemed that so many of the rules
that were coming down
because it was all done under an
emergency order there didn't have to be
the same level of scrutiny by multiple
levels of government and I've got an
excerpt here that I'm going to play in
just a second of an example that's of
that that was really striking to me was
when the County of Los Angeles
uh banned all outdoor dining this was in
2021 so this was after the freedom uh
index the list Freedom index report but
um the answers that they were giving to
people as to why this was justified were
virtually non-existent and I'll just
play the clip because you'll you'll hear
the health director who had the power
over this entire huge region that is you
know as populated as many states
um it was kind of just like it came down
to what she believed was the right thing
without any checks or balance on
November 22nd Los Angeles became the
only County in America to ban outdoor
dining this winter for a minimum of
three weeks this order could put out of
business many California restaurants
that were barely hanging on some of
which recently invested in retrofitting
for exclusively outdoor dining the worst
part according to critics is that the
public health agency issuing the order
has provided no concrete evidence that
outdoor dining is a significant source
of covid spread I personally feel like
we're being punished LA Public Health
director Barbara Farrer held an online
press conference on November 23rd to
discuss the order and estimates from the
County's contact tracing that 10 to 15
percent of covid Transmissions are
linked to dining experiences though she
hasn't clarified how many of those
Transmissions were attributed to outdoor
dining at restaurants and declined to
provide the underlying data when pressed
by reporters given that you haven't
identified an actual source of an
outbreak being an outdoor dining how do
you wrap nationalize the closure and how
do you expect to measure whether it
actually is accomplishing what you're
hoping to accomplish we know that places
where people are gathering without
wearing their face coverings are places
where transmission is easiest and most
likely
um but we will be you know as always
we'll watch our data
it was always a kind of like we'll we'll
keep an eye on it uh so my question is
when you're measuring the rule of law or
trying to quantify that what what are
you looking at and and how do you take
things like states of emergency or
states of exception into account when
you're measuring that
so we're not uh the rule of law is very
difficult to measure it's not like
measuring a tariff rate or you know the
the size of government that that kind of
thing is is difficult so it's it's based
on what a lot of experts feel but I
think that we use measures that are
reasonable
um but they're looking at the same
indicators over time and
um and so the different indicators of
rule of law that we look at are ones
that have to do with contract ones that
have to do with private property uh
protection uh rule uh due process type
uh indicators and
um we're not uh we're not making a
special measurement to take into account
emergency measures whether they're
Justified or not
um what we're seeing is a decrease in
the rule of law and part of a the
decrease in the rule of law because it's
really um
uh partially a perceptions uh based
indicator more than than many others is
do people think that the rules of the
game are fair or are being imposed in an
arbitrary way and and so on and actually
that matters in a free Society what the
perception is of the rules of the game
matters to be able to uphold
um the system of justice and other
freedoms so what we've seen is a
deterioration during this time where I
think you can make the case that there
were a lot of arbitrary decisions being
made it's quite another question about
uh whether that was constitutional at
the state level or even uh at the
federal level but I think at least in
the early parts of the pandemic when we
didn't have very much information about
the spread or even about the the disease
um a courts were probably more uh
we're probably more reluctant to impose
orders that overrode uh what the
democratic system was yeah
um decided I mean by late by middle and
late 2021 we did have courts starting to
smack down some of these Governors and
uh Mayors this is a little Montage of
headlines in Michigan Pennsylvania
California all got Federal rulings
against some of their restrictions which
were deemed arbitrary discriminating
against certain categories without any
you know rational basis the big one was
obviously the Supreme Court
smacking down the OSHA mandate that was
requiring private employers to either
vaccinate or test their employees so it
was a delayed but there eventually was
some sort of judicial intervention I
assume that uh you know in the the
future uh you know human Freedom index
that that will be a mark in favor of
rule of law in the U.S that that there
is you know still some checks and
balances in play here
yeah I would I would expect that uh yeah
but again you know we we take the data
and sometimes we you know we we might
not agree totally with it but we don't
tamper with it we take the data the
third party sources uh provide right can
we uh show uh Zach could you show the
just the the chart that shows the
decline in 2020
again
um Ian is this uh you know uh that's the
wrong one in um yeah that I mean first
off can you just very quickly and I'm
what I'm thinking here is uh the old
Robert Higgs book crisis in Leviathan
which is kind of uh among other things
is a a generalized theory of government
power in the way that it grows and that
when there is a crisis when there is a
war when there is an economic collapse
things like that
um the government generally expands its
power and then after the crisis passes
they're you know it doesn't completely
revert back to where it was except in
very rare
um instances and you know you you
mentioned in 2007 being the peak I mean
the the global financial crisis same to
us you're in an era of like a lessening
of uh you know of of freedom of human
Freedom overall it comes back a little
bit it starts going down down and then
obviously covet really hits but my
question I guess is broadly speaking is
this what you're you know what you're
tracking is a kind of crisis in
Leviathan mindset and then you know in
general and then what explains the ramp
up between 2000 and 2007 like why was
the globe getting Freer
um was there you know what was going on
where suddenly you know people people
had more freedom yeah those are good
questions
um Robert Higgs was mainly looking at
the United States right when he made
that that study and so this is a global
chart that that was up on the screen and
so I hesitate to make such a broad uh
statement about so many different
distinct countries around the world but
I do think that that analysis still
applies to the United States if you look
at a graph of freedom of the United
States and particularly of economic
freedom
um what you see is after the financial
crisis a decline in Freedom the in
economic freedom that was rather sharp
um it lasted during a good part of of
the Obama administrations but then at
the end of the Obama Administration we
see an uptick in economic freedom in the
United States you know some of the some
of the uh big spending came to an end as
the country recovered and so on and what
with with Trump coming into office we
saw that continue in the first a year or
two and then
by the last part of his administration
we saw it come down and obviously in
2020 it really fell off so and maybe uh
I I take your point that we don't want
to generalize from the U.S experience to
all other countries but in the U.S when
Bush became president in 2000 and the
Republicans you know ran the uh Congress
both of the Congress in Bush's two terms
not only did we have the wars in
Afghanistan and Iraq but we also had
effectively a uh 50 increase in the
federal budget uh Bill Clinton's last
budget was around 2 trillion by the time
bush left it was like 4 trillion
um you know how did how you know was the
was kind of governmental spending and
increases in regulation and economically
significant regulations things that cost
more than 100 million dollars to
implement we was that being offset by
other forms of Freedom or no the the
United States doesn't track uh if you
look at the graph of freedom in the
United States it doesn't look like the
global the global graph it didn't it
wasn't increasing uh okay that's that's
one of the worrisome things that that we
found because you asked why is there
this increase it's because all sorts of
other countries were still increasing
their freedom around the world not the
United States the United States is a
very worrisome Trend starting from
around the year 2000 of a long-term
steady decline in Freedom that then with
the with the global financial crisis it
it it it accelerated and
um and
we especially see that beginning in the
year 2000 in the economic freedom side
of things because of exactly the kinds
of things that you mentioned and out of
the five different indicators in in
economic freedom about broad categories
that we look at size of government the
legal system and property rights sound
money freedom to trade and regulation
all of them saw notable drops during
during this uh period of time
except that the rule of law indicator
saw the biggest drop it was a it was a
very big drop and that accelerated with
the financial crisis but that was
already going on and it really started
uh with the beginning of the Bush
Administration and we think that that's
due to a lot of things
um the wars the war on terror uh the War
on Drugs
um the weakening of private property
rights in the United States with the
kilo decision over a decade ago
um I think that the financial crisis
made things worse because there was a
rise of crony capitalism or at least
what people perceived as crony
capitalism where Industries and and in
fact particular companies close to power
uh got privileges and massive amounts of
bailouts even though uh that that wasn't
necessarily Justified and all of these
things combined to to weaken the rule of
law because it's it's arbitrary and at
the very least that's perceived as such
and when you have the rules of the game
not uh not viewed as as Fair that's a
real threat to other freedoms but we did
see other other areas of Freedom like uh
government spending and uh monetary
policy and freedom to trade start to
start to go down as well and this
uh accelerated during the financial
crisis it started to recover some and
with the pandemic it it came down never
did the United States recover its level
of Freedom that it had in the year 2000
um when it when it used to rank at the
top in the year 2000
the United States ranked sixth in our
human Freedom index it now ranks 23. so
this this is it particularly I want to
show that chart uh yeah here's the
ranking we've got uh Switzerland New
Zealand Estonia Denmark Ireland rounding
out the top five and then you go down
U.S at 23 below Belgium and Austria and
the United Kingdom uh pretty sad uh
here's a here's a breakdown of the
analysis of the United States as you
mentioned rule of law as a is it a
meager 6.3
um movement 6.4 affected negatively by
the pandemic of course size of
government 6.8
what's our what are some of the
immediate steps that should be taken to
you know reverse these Trends and you
know get the us at least back into the
top 10 of you know Freedom ranked
countries
well I mean there's a lot that can be
done in terms of economic freedom we're
way below in in economic freedom than
what we were in the year 2000 and that
that in terms of
free trade in terms of regulations in
terms of
um sound money uh in in every indicator
we're we're below and so all of those
policies can can be improved the size of
government is is much larger today after
Obama after Trump uh during the after
Bush right after Bush it's just much
larger than one Bush yeah if I may in
2019 because this you know when we talk
about the the covid exception
2019 spending this was under Donald
Trump uh and it was a record at the time
that the federal budget spent four or
federal government spent 4.4 trillion
dollars in 2020 it's been 6.6 trillion
dollars in 2021 6.8 last year it went
down to 6.3 slightly this year it's
estimated to be 6.4 and this is you know
this seems to vindicate the uh the Higgs
hypothesis of a kind of ratchet effect
so you know it's gone down from 6.8
percent but it's much closer to that
than it is to 4.4 which was already
insane compared to you know Bill Clinton
uh 20 years earlier
that's right so I think that that that
that
hypothesis is still valid for the United
States after these these crises and um
you know there were several crises
during the Bush Administration which
which did help to increase government
spending at a time at least in his the
first part of his administration where
the Republicans controlled both you know
uh the the Congress and the executive
and um that's oftentimes not a good
thing yeah and it's interesting now not
to get too into Weeds about uh you know
government uh spending in America but
you know when when Obama came in uh in
2009 he of course he won what was con
you know what was rightly considered a
mandate at the time and the Democrats
took they uh they had control of the
house but they took control of the
Senate he he did have a blank check for
two years and spending went up and they
got everything they wanted basically and
that elected a republican Congress and
then things started leveling off I mean
I'm not a huge fan of divided government
because it's you know at various points
it seems as if you know spending just
keeps going up anyway but
um you know at least in uh the late Bush
years and the the second half of Obama
things leveled off a bit because it it
seemed uh you know a divided government
put the put the brakes on certain
specific
so uh behind all of these Trends is how
people view government and how people
feel about society and and politics and
and so on and one of the things that we
but we see is when you look at the
global picture and you see the high
point at 2007 and then it starts going
down with the financial crisis that's a
period of time where you you really see
the rise of different forms of populism
during during this uh subsequent period
of time all over the world authoritarian
populism of the left of the right uh in
a lot of countries is taking over and in
a lot of political systems having a
bigger say in politics including in
Liberal democracies as occur has
occurred in the United States I would
argue in both parties
um
the the the what happened I think in the
United States uh beginning during the
Bush Administration
um which as I say had its own crises and
expanded uh the role of government so it
was reducing freedom is if you look at
the at the
um surveys by Pew and by Gallup you see
that over the past 15 to 20 years in the
United States trust in almost every
institution in society starts coming
down and it's it's hitting record lows
on so many different institutions we're
talking about
um the the uh the media uh Congress the
exactly the things like the Catholic
church and philanthropies are actually
also saying
um uh businesses you know big businesses
and and other kinds of businesses and so
when when there is a loss of trust in
the main institutions in society that
mediate uh interaction in society uh
you're in Latin American territory and
that's when Trump came in and that's I I
very much view Trump as a Latin American
populist uh but I think that he didn't
come out of nowhere something was going
on in the United States that led people
to think hey you know the rules of the
game aren't aren't Fair anymore we don't
trust this institution or that
institution yeah and both he and Hillary
Clinton this was uh striking to me in
the right rhetoric in 2016 they both
explicitly said the system is broken you
know they offered different reasons for
why it was broken what was broken in it
and how they would fix it but it was uh
fairly chilling and you know and I think
on some profound level accurate I mean
certainly there's a reason why they were
the candidates and they were both saying
the system is broken you can't trust the
system the system doesn't care about you
it's not watching out for you but of
course they took no responsibility for
that system no no of course been a part
of it I think that's been a really big
problem for for especially for the
Democrats who um uh have a lot of uh
correct gripes about uh Republicans or
or Trump uh they themselves have become
at least a big part of the the
democrators have become more radicalized
but they don't take into account the
role that their ideas had and continue
to have in creating the political
polarization I very much see the uh the
political polarization in the United
States and the and what's going on now
as a legacy of Obama and even of bush so
um unfortunately
um I don't think that there has been a
great
um explanation uh so far or analysis of
why that has happened and
um we can come up with a lot of
plausible stories that I think can
um be compelling but the fact of the
matter is that this polarization and
this rise of populisms either on the
left or right or both has been going on
All Around the World in countries that
are completely different from one
another in terms of wealth in terms of
the political system in terms of culture
I mean we're talking about this
happening in Mexico and Chile two very
different uh societies and in India and
in Hungary and you know the the
hardening of nationalisms and so on in
Russia and in China turkey and in parts
of Western Europe where major political
parties have become uh radicalized or
include very radical uh parties as part
of their coalitions can you talk uh
briefly I mean you you study and focus
on Latin America and a lot of your work
and you know this is one of the most
tragic segments of the world or areas in
the world where it seemed as if Latin
America broadly speaking had been doing
very well kind or you know was moving in
the right direction after the end of the
Cold War
um and you know many of the countries
including places like Chile and
Argentina had started to account for the
autocratic governments that you know had
ruled uh for decades and things like
that and it just seems like you know
Latin America is back to a kind of large
basket case what went on there and how
did covid
um either exacerbate or or moderate that
decline oh yeah I mean covert made
things much worse I mean what's happened
in in Latin America over the past
several years is this the return of the
left the and not just the the
moderate modern left which had been
alternating in power in many countries
over the past a couple of decades and
and sensibly upholding reasonable
policies that I'm talking about the
return of the populist that left and
um that's been a huge disappointment I
think that much of it would not have
happened if it weren't for covid
upending society and making people feel
um unsafe and that's when the
opportunists the political opportunities
come out of the woodwork and that
happens in every country but in
countries that don't have
um well-established or long-standing
institutions and institutional
safeguards like the United States has
um you can wash away all sorts of
institutional progress or freedoms uh
very quickly and I think that that's um
that's what's happened in in a lot of
Latin America there has been progress in
the region it has been positive and the
progress hasn't just been in terms of
policies and institutions in terms of
Greater freedoms and notably so over the
past uh 20 to 30 years in in the region
it's been in terms of every indicator of
human well-being some countries much
more than than others and so we have as
classical liberals or Advocates of
liberal democracy a big challenge
because it's undeniable that the ideas
that we uphold the policies the
institutions and the values are indeed
what have led to the big increases is in
life spans the drops in human in infant
mortality rates the big access to Safe
Drinking Water the big increases in per
capita income in the countries that have
most adopted uh these ideas and yet if
success stories like chili and Chile is
one of the great developing country
success stories of all time uh by any
indicator any objective indicator the
progress It's Made just blows away the
rest of Latin America
if a country that has had so much
success like that by implementing these
policies can so easily elect a far left
president on the argument that
everything that came before was unfair
and
um has to be overturned which was the
the platform then we have a big
challenge because it's not enough to
point to facts we have to appeal to the
the the the moral argument of a free
society and we have to appeal to sense
of of justice and then explain that
because I think I think that every
country in Latin America has a different
explanation I don't think there's one
explanation for the rise of populism and
the decline of freedom in in countries
around the world but I do think that
there are sets of factors and they
belong they explain more particular
factors explain more what happened in
this country in that country in Chile I
think the the role of ideology played a
very big role in which the the the left
um created a narrative and took over it
had a really hegemonic position in in
society and all the cultural
institutions the media the the
universities the the even even
businessmen didn't actually defend the
achievements of a free society and the
pillars of a free Society so that in
Chile everybody knew that the country
was unfair that inequality had grown it
hadn't it had declined until he's less
than equal to most of than the average
Latin American country now that the same
people are always getting rich in this
the poor are always at that level that's
not it's one of the most has most social
mobility in many countries is the
narrative was what was informing
Chileans and there weren't enough and I
know the people in Chile admire them who
are on our side but there weren't enough
of them making the moral case for this
tremendous progress that Chile had had
achieved so progress is uh progress can
can be had incredible progress like that
is unprecedented in human history can be
had but nothing uh we can't be
um deterministic about it it can be
rolled back particularly if people
believe that
um it's on somehow unfair or that
actually things are getting worse in the
world and if that's the case then we
have to roll back the the policies and
create new ones and make America great
Again by protectionism or some something
like that you know so I think that Chile
has a bit is a
uh is a warning story to the United
States uh because uh there you you had a
an ideology in this case of of the left
that was really informing everything and
um I find that particularly the
ideologies of the left are are more
Insidious because they present
themselves as being somehow morally
Superior whereas
um the ideologies of the far right are
ugly on their face you know we don't
like the foreigners and these guys are
bad and these guys are our enemies and
they're the and the ideology of the left
purport
to to uh be on the side of the the
disadvantaged and so on when in fact
um we know that they're not and it also
leads to all the problems of the loss of
centralization and authoritarianism
so I I think we have to in the United
States also be very uh watchful of that
uh because in Chile it snuck up on
society and and
um thankfully the Chileans have rejected
a radical uh constitutional overhaul now
they're going to start with another one
so I'm not as pessimistic about Chile as
I was
um you know last year but it's still uh
going to take a step back
that you're that your discussion of
populism there you know makes me think
about the question of democracy and like
what role does that play in Secure
either securing or in other cases
undermining freedom I mean in your
report you kind of say that you you
don't measure democracy as one of the
components but that it's highly
correlated with free societies so what
exactly is the relationship between
democracy and freedom because these
populists can kind of harness a
democratic energy to then later come in
and impose
anti-democratic authoritarianism so how
do you view the the relationship
um as a whole that's right so we're not
in our in our index we're not measuring
excuse me as part of the index political
uh freedom but we think that's important
uh and and we measure you know democracy
or political Freedom separately in order
to look at the relationship between
human freedom and political Freedom what
we're looking at are are
um our actual indicators of Freedom uh
actual indicators of uh whether there is
or isn't uh coercion and political
freedom is is a mechanism to make
decisions about whether the policy
should be this or that and the policy
could reduce your freedom or it could
increase your your freedom what we find
is that there is a strong relationship
like you said between human freedom and
democracy but
um that's just the overall relationship
and we've seen I mean the the Latin
America is a good case study of this um
all of the authoritarianisms there uh in
the last couple of decades came in as
elected democracies that then proceeded
to eliminate freedoms and for a large
part of the time they were popular
but there weren't the safeguards that we
think of when we talk about liberal
democracy and and so when I think about
the optimal political regime I think of
liberal democracy that's limited limited
power uh and uh democracy itself is a
very uh much much broader term and um
not and and so I would say most
democracies in the world are actually
liberal ill liberal democracies uh that
can very easily turn into authoritarian
uh regimes as clearly was the case in
Venezuela clearly is the case in uh
Nicaragua
um I think that's happening in El
Salvador and in a few other places I
think Mexico is under threat of that
occurring uh Mexico is moving strongly
in the direction of less Freedom under
the populist uh president there in a way
that I think uh people outside of Mexico
including in Latin America don't fully
appreciate the kind of uh inverse
example to that to what you're
describing there in Latin America which
has been just haunting and horrifying to
me to watch unfold is the situation in
Hong Kong and you use that as a case
study in the human Freedom index that
this is showing Hong Kong's ranking
we've we've all seen what's happened as
China's reasserted the Chinese
government has restarted control over
Hong Kong this is the ranking uh which
essentially started in 2000 or you know
right around there so right so this is
showing you know the the sharp decline
in Freedom of Association and assembly
starting around 20 what I guess 2015
there so uh I and I've got a clip from I
covered Hong Kong I went over there
amidst the protests that were happening
I want to play a clip of some of the the
demonstrators and the the pro-democracy
activists talking about what values are
important to them and then get your
reaction as to what has happened to Hong
Kong and and what lessons the world
should drop from this example of a
not very Democratic but fairly liberal
Society backsliding so quickly
well USA we are
safeguarding uh the freedom to
speak our minds to take our political
stance to protest without fear of being
prosecuted 15 years ago we had a higher
level of freedom of freedom of speech in
or in in various aspects but now it
seems that we can feel Hong Kong
becoming more and more like China in
terms of political values I I always
believe that one of the biggest capture
in Hong Kong and the Beijing government
the emphasis on rule of law freedom
freedom of speech human rights at the
moment I have to say that I'm pretty
pessimistic because it's just so
difficult
to stop China from extending the kind of
power and control that they wish for in
a way I think many of us are probably
even thinking that what we're trying to
do right now is to slow down the change
in the wrong direction
preserving whatever we got from one
country to system at the moment
so what what lessons would you draw from
the example of Hong Kong
well I mean the the fact of the matter
is that Hong Kong is just a very unique
case study this is a this is a country
that was um ruled colonially by Great
Britain and
um then was handed over in 1997 to to
China under the agreement that it would
still keep its autonomy and its its
fairy free market system Hong Kong has
long been number one in terms of
economic freedom in our in our
measurements I think that that's that's
uh weakened
um the the economic freedom ratings have
started to weaken and so that made it a
very unusual uh uh situation where you
had high levels of civil liberties
personal Liberties and economic freedoms
and based on a very strong uh rule of
law which was part of the uh British uh
inheritance and and the kinds of
policies that England and Great Britain
were implementing a bigger government
more regulation and so on back home
we're not adopted in Hong Kong so Hong
Kong maintained that high level of
Freedom which is why it became one of
the richest places on Earth and and has
been called appropriately so kind of a
miracle uh economy but it didn't have
um political freedom and that made it
very unusual I think that the the time
when Hong kongers began to call for more
and more freedoms was really grew uh
with the Handover to to Beijing because
of course there was inevitably this
uncertainty about what would happen and
for the first 10 or almost 50 10 or 15
years actually China respected that and
Hong Kong maintained a very high level
of of freedom and in a very strange
situation occurred I I I've traveled
there a lot and during that time period
I went and um there were democracy
activists who wanted to promote
democracy and have more of a say over
their own uh of the city and
um they tended however to be more uh
left oriented so they wanted to impose
more regulations on business and minimum
wage laws and those and more welfare
benefits and that kind of thing the kind
of thing that is normal in most liberal
democracies today
but that really wasn't the case in in
Hong Kong and it was Beijing that was
opposing them at that time to be able to
maintain the free market system this is
the Communist Party in in China opposing
them and the business Community which
would otherwise be favorable to
democracy in Hong Kong didn't rely uh
with the Democracy movement because the
Democracy movement was vilifying the the
business community so very odd politics
occurred in which I think a lot of
Concepts were being confused and I went
to the legislative Council one day and
one of their the famous
pro-democracy Advocates was there the
legislative council is there their form
of of little congress with limited
powers and this guy was called long hair
that was his nickname and he was on the
floor of the legislative Council wearing
advocating for more democracy and
wearing a chege about a T-shirt and he's
an enemy of the Communist Party in China
who at that time was supporting the free
market system so it's kind of a funny
thing all of that changed uh when Xi
Jinping came to power so what we see in
Hong Kong today is really a reflection
of his
um Power grab in China and his rollback
of the freedoms that China had been
increasing and maintaining for the last
several decades and which is responsible
for the absolute transformation of China
and making it a much richer and dynamic
country he's rolling that back and and
that's what he's doing in Hong Kong as
well and that start and you can see that
happening on the graph of of Hong Kong
around 2014 it just starts to go down
and then and then more and more steadily
and then of course in the year 2020 they
passed the the National Security Law in
Beijing which effectively took away uh
Hong Kong's uh autonomy and reduce it's
it's freedoms and changed the whole
system do you think in China now and
there are reports that you know mainland
China now has a lower economic growth
rate than most Asian countries pretty
much for the first time in the past 20
or 25 years
um is that going to you know and and
China certainly had a very brutal uh
repressive regime related to covid uh
you know this was you know in in many
cases this was the first time people in
the west started taking covet seriously
when you saw the footage of you know
people being uh you know uh nailed into
their apartments and things like that so
they couldn't move because they were
suspected or or had or had coveted
um do you think that the economic slump
of China will work to undermine
um you know the support or the you know
uh for uh ji's regime uh if you know and
and I guess I'm going back to it's a
haunting question and that are you know
uh kind of paradox that you brought up
that in a place like Chile you have
Rising Prosperity but the narrative is
that things are getting worse and worse
and that has actual political effect in
a place like China much more
authoritarian country but if people are
actually falling behind you know the the
growth rates have slowed down their
growth rates relative to other countries
around them are slowing down well that
uh you know will that have positive
effects on pushing for for increased
freedom in China
well I I
the Xi Jinping is already losing uh
popularity because of the measures that
they took during covid but I'm afraid
that uh it's still not going to be
enough uh because it already is a
totalitarian regime they have a
tremendous amount of police power and
control
in a way that
um wasn't the case uh at the beginning
of his uh of when he came to power and
he's just been extending that he's China
is basically facing
um the dictator's dilemma which is that
as a poor and authoritarian regime
liberalizes economically and grows uh
economically which is certainly what
what China has done people by definition
are more free and more prosperous I mean
you the control of the economy is the
control of life itself so when you
liberalize you have more more freedom
and then people are more independent of
the state and also are going to want
more of their other kind and this we
should point out also is you know Milton
Friedman talked about this uh in you
know things like free to choose and
whatnot but in the 80s as uh once the
economy in China was liberalized post
now
um you know at the end of the decade you
saw the uh democracy movement uh most
spectacularly in tmn square Friedman was
saying you know look once again I'm
proven right when you get economic
freedom people get rich wealthier people
start to demand political Freedom here
we go and of course it didn't quite work
out that way well but I think there's no
question that the Chinese uh are more
even today are much much Freer than they
were in 1980 and yeah certainly richer
and so on what Xi Jinping is doing is
that he's realizing that if he keeps
going in the direction of liberalization
and uh the growth that it that it it
produces uh the Communist party is going
to lose control because it's it's by
definition that's the process that all
sorts of authoritarian regimes that have
liberalized economically have gone
through and that eventually ending up
with political freedoms and democracy
Chile did it Mexico did it Taiwan South
Korea and so on and so forth and he
doesn't want to lose control so what
he's doing is he's rolling back those
freedoms but that has a cost the cost is
economic growth the cost is civil unrest
and nobody knows what's going to happen
I think that China is essentially an
ungovernable country but it has become
our totalitarian and that's the problem
I think that there's going to be very
hard times in China and it's it's not
clear what direction it'll go but I'm
hopeful that it will that it will remain
an essentially ungovernable country and
maybe that will open up some spaces for
for change
how do the economic how do you think the
economic and either political or social
freedoms work in concert in the other
direction because I was thinking back to
the example of the United States with
this if we pull up this slide again of
the different Freedom indicators we've
got you know we're sliding on things
like rule of law and size of government
but then you go down to like personal
relationships which would include
same-sex marriages you know ability to
divorce uh women's uh you know equal
rights and relationships that we're at a
perfect 10 there
um are these things just kind of is
there a cleavage happening there uh or
does one kind of tend to in a delayed
fashion follow the other if we look at
other examples around the world
well one thing that we find remember
that this is a 30 000 foot view of each
of each country and of freedoms in
general
um one thing that we find is that
there's a strong relationship between
economic freedom and personal freedoms I
like to tell people who who appreciate
personal freedoms that if you want to
live in a country with a high level of
personal freedom you better pick a
country with a relatively higher level
of economic freedom because the two go
hand in hand and we know that there's
plenty of Human Rights Advocates or
Advocates of freedom of the press or
people who have uh good intentions to
promote certain freedoms that uh don't
fully appreciate economic freedom or or
even hostile to it and so this is a
that's an important finding empirical
finding that comes out of this study but
um I don't think that that we can say
that there's a this regularity when this
goes up this other thing goes down
um in three years or with a two-year lag
it's not as simple as that I mean I
think that in the United States as we've
seen both personal and economic freedoms
have have gone down
um but you're right there are things
like
um uh relationship issues that are much
better now than they were 10 years ago
and notably so I think that this is
something that we don't measure because
there's not uh reliable International
comparable data but drug drug
prohibition or drug freedom I think that
has improved in the United States not as
much as we might like so that's an
improvement but other things like
freedom of expression I think are I have
become more problematic in the United
States even if the first amendment is
still strong we have cultural issues and
that's important of freedom of
expression uh and um
and you want to maintain a a culture
that is supportive of freedom of
expression or more broadly speak
tolerance rather than intolerance of
various different views and Lifestyles
and I think that that's that's that's a
big problem for a free society and
um we we're still uh in the United
States
um wrestling with that yeah can I um
also just uh to kind of expand a little
bit on what what counts as economic
freedom one of the things that
particularly for American Libertarians
is that we assume all of Europe is
somehow you know a left-wing Haven and
whatnot and again I mean both uh your
economic rankings as well as uh you know
the Heritage Foundation and Simon Frey
Simon Fraser University you find
reliably countries like Sweden
um uh you know having a higher rate of
economic freedom on these indices and
and you know whereas everybody's like
Sweden is a socialist Paradise could you
talk a little bit about what are the
economic freedom uh indicators that
really
um that ultimately matter in terms of
you know human Freedom
um because it's not simply what the top
Mark top marginal tax rate is right
um what what goes into that
you know that's a that's a tough
question I mean when we when we measure
economic freedom we're measuring size of
government the the rule of law we're
measuring uh sound money and Regulation
and trade those are the broad the broad
areas and you know we've some years ago
I asked uh Jim gwartney and the authors
of the economic freedom what what do
they think are what really uh is
critical I think that at different
stages of development you might have
different answers right but um one of
the things that that we found was that
if a country doesn't improve its uh rule
of law indicator above a certain level
it doesn't tend to improve in other
areas very much or
grow as much as countries that continue
to improve uh in that area so I think
that the that the legal system that the
rule of law indicators are are are
critical uh especially as a country is
developing and you know you have
countries like Sweden like France like
you know your Western European countries
the United States too that has a long
tradition of a sound rule of law it came
out of 800 years of building that up and
developing countries don't don't have
that
um that is what uh that and and limited
government historically is what led to
uh the the the rich World becoming rich
it also allowed uh government the size
of government to increase and and and I
think that that's a decrease in in
economic freedom but it's the kind of
thing that can happen in a country that
has sound institutions that lead to
wealth and then you can make what I
would call a mistake and not pay for it
in the same way that is true of
developing countries that don't have
that institutional basis and when they
make mistakes
um it costs them more because they're
poor and it has a bigger a bigger cost
so comparing Sweden with with the United
States Sweden has higher taxes and a
bigger welfare welfare state but you
know it's also a relatively free uh free
trade country uh its regulations are not
that that high it has things
um like many European countries that are
Freer school choice
um no minimum wage things like that that
yeah so the the labor regulations not
not counting minimum wage it's much
harder to fire somebody in Sweden but
it's much easier to run a business
otherwise and I think you know one of
the Achilles heels or maybe blind spots
of the American libertarian movement has
been that it you know it doesn't do
Nuance very well it just looks at the
percentage of government spending you
know as a as an expression of GDP and if
it's bigger then it's worse uh and it's
not always that case and and I know Zach
is going to ask you a final question
um but before we get to that you had
talked about you know the decline in
trust and confidence in institutions in
the United States and if you go back uh
you know both in the book that I wrote
with Matt Welch the Declaration of
Independence and an assorted I think in
2019 I talked a lot about that this has
become a it started becoming a fixation
of mine in the bush years because the
decline in trust and the confidence of
government and you know virtually every
aspect of society just became so
apparent and if you go back to Gallup
and a couple of other polling Services
it really starts in the late 60s and the
early 70s for absolutely good reasons a
lot of businesses but especially
government you know and especially the
federal government has just lied and
cheated and done poorly and not owned up
to its mistakes not tried to fix it
the question between the hollowing out
of trust and confidence in government
and other institutions what is the
contribution do you think that
libertarian rhetoric has made over you
know the past half century
um or so because the argument that
Libertarians always make is that
government or an increasing number of
people within the libertarian movement
say government is always incompetent you
know at best it's incompetent at worst
it's actually malevolent and and it has
evil intent we hear that again and again
Reagan you know very famously and
successfully co-opted libertarian
rhetoric when he said you know the
government isn't the answer to your
problems government is the problem
um do Libertarians do you think and you
know you bro you use the term at one
point classical liberal
um you know do Libertarians need to do a
better job of kind of sussing out what
is the legitimate role of government and
what are the legitimate functions versus
this blanken condemnation which very
much goes to complaints you know that
lead to populism that government is
corrupt government is evil government is
inefficient Etc
probably so I think that the term size
of government has been misused a lot to
to only mean how much government spends
and um the contribution of Libertarians
I think is to have a proper skepticism
of power that's what you saw in the
night in the 1960s and so on and I think
that that was a healthy thing absolutely
whereas the kinds of
um
fall and trust that I think we've been
seeing now has been a a skepticism of
Institutions themselves almost that this
is my own particular read of things
um and you know throw throw it all out
we can't trust any of it and I think
maybe that's that's grounded in in
something and that something is what we
as Libertarians have to get a hold of I
think that the the right way to talk
about things is the proper role of
government people think
um the size of government is too big and
it turns off some people because
um it it it it doesn't necessarily uh
mean
um
imply
um I don't know I I think that
the economists among Libertarians have
mostly made that argument and well I
think it's correct it doesn't really
capture everything and and most people
don't think in those terms to begin with
and so you want to I think talk more
about the proper role of government and
I think that we need to
um ask ourselves why in the last 15 20
years in the United States we've seen
this decline in trust how is it
different than in other times and I
don't feel like
um many people are asking that question
well or answering that question well
enough and I think that that
Libertarians probably have can have a
better insight into that
thank you yeah so the the if if the
proper role of government is at least in
in my mind to protect these freedoms
that you are trying to measure
um it does I I want to return to that
question I actually have two final
wrap-ups but they're they're related and
the the first the first is
um that question of what is freedom what
is this Freedom that is worth protecting
um and you laid out that there's a lot
of different different definitions of
freedom and you are focused on one very
specific definition
why could you just make the case for why
that is the proper definition or why
that is the thing that we should be
focused on increasing
in countries around the world and and by
the way the definition
um am I right to say that it's uh
fundamentally it's freedom from coercion
that's right and um I think you know not
everybody has to agree with that and
indeed not everybody does some people
just totally disagree with that but I
think that it does appeal to a lot of
people to be the author of their own
lives and it does have us an appeal to
people to say people should have the
right to express their conscious to talk
about what they think uh as long as
they're not harming somebody to Worship
in the way that they want as long as
it's not harming somebody and so there's
an inherent value the first and most
important reason to use that
um uh as a definition is because there's
an inherent value and even if you are
the type of person that believes in all
sorts of other freedoms positive
freedoms like the right to have a house
and that kind of thing which I don't
really think are true rights
um most of those people even though
they're in contradiction also believe in
freedom of expression and these other
freedoms and so I think that it has as
wide appeal as you can can get uh with
people but beyond that we also know that
freedom plays a central role in human
progress we can see the the relationship
uh the strong relationship between
freedom and prosperity and indicators of
human well-being across the board and
that's important to point out as well so
when um when countries uh have less
Freedom they just don't have as as
higher highest standard of living as the
countries that have high freedoms one of
the things that we've noticed in this
era of globalization though is that
there's been a tremendous Improvement in
human well-being all around the world
that's that's a that is a huge Triumph
of Classical liberalism because we're
talking about a world that has become
more free uh not just within countries
but globally and one of the the
worrisome aspects of the United States
loss in Freedom is the following when
you look at countries that are less free
even in those countries even in
countries that have that haven't done
much to improve their freedom you see
notable improvements in human well-being
what is literally happening is that the
free countries are lifting up all of
humanity because in the poorest
countries you see people using cell
phones taking medicines that are
invented in in free countries benefiting
from Capital that comes in from free
countries the freedom of the free
benefits not only the free it benefits
everybody as Hayek observed more than 50
years ago and I think that this is a
good example of that and so that's one
more reason why the loss of freedom in
the United States is really bad news not
just for Americans but for the world I
would you know not to launch us into a
six-hour conversation about this but
with the mention of Hayek I think it's
worth thinking about I I agree
fundamentally that freedom from coercion
is a fundamental perhaps the fundamental
part of any definition of freedom but
Hayek in books like the constitution of
Liberty and elsewhere also talked not
quite in terms of positive rights that
you have a right to a house you have a
right to a job but that he believed in a
social welfare state uh that oftentimes
I find in conversations with most people
who call themselves libertarian would
say any transfer payment is not just
ineffective and inefficient but is
immoral and it's interesting because
Hayek as a classical liberal did not
believe that he supported a social
welfare state and that one measure of
freedom and I don't know how you do this
without you know just opening up like an
endless you know uh expansion of this
but that if you don't have uh you know
if you don't have the ability or the
freedom to participate in society
because you are born poor and there is
no education offered you or you know you
you grow up in certain circumstances is
that you know negative negative freedoms
don't quite get to a flourishing Society
um that is going to continue to grow but
yeah so there is uh an argument for some
base uh level of of helping out the the
less fortunate um but you know we're so
far away from that world with the
basketball welfare states and this
functionality of a big government that
I'm yeah I'm happy to have that
discussion when we when we actually have
to to deal with that reality instead I
think that what what we have is a
situation where Libertarians point to
this move toward greater freedom in many
countries around the world and including
in the United States up until the year
2000 or whatever
um but there needs to be probably a lot
more drilling down because
um most people in their lives are not
assessing every single aspect of freedom
and weighing it on the same uh scale
um maybe what's happened in the United
States is that some things that didn't
used to be political are much more
politically decided today even if
monetary policy is better than 30 years
ago and so much more is at stake with
the political system that affects
people's lives than used to be the case
and maybe that's what people are
reacting to I heard Mark and Reese in I
think it was him say
um you know all these things are are
becoming better but if you look at
housing and education and health care
even though everything else has seen
prices drop those prices have
skyrocketed of course that's where
government is more involved but people
that's where that's the American dream
right but it's also true I mean this is
where you know it's also true that
housing is better health care I mean
it's much more expensive but it's also
that's really increased right that's
that's right too um I don't know about
Transportation I don't know but you know
one of the other things that is
interesting and you see this at you know
Zach on that side of Texas you see this
in Texas and Florida which are the two
you know most successful large
population states of the past 20 years
really probably the past 50 years but in
each of them uh because of coven or
partly under the auspices of covid
you've also seen a shift at what level
do political decisions get made they are
much more likely to be made at the state
house or in the governor's mansion
rather than in the local school district
uh or like that local businesses can't
decide certain things we saw this again
and again and that's an interesting
Wrinkle In you know in in kind of levels
of freedom in America you know I I think
everybody would probably agree that
Texas and Florida compared to say
California and New York are much more
free uh States certainly economically
and and their economies kind of reflect
that they're growing that's where people
are moving and yet at the same level
we're starting to see the governor's
assert that I have the right to say what
books are taught or what what the
curriculum is everywhere what businesses
can and can't do what masking policy uh
things you know it it's an interesting
question to ask I I don't think we'll
um have the time to get into it but you
know in the wake of covid what are the
long tail kind of shifts that may end up
re you know kind of uh re-centering
American politics and particularly what
counts as a conservative uh your way of
governing versus a liberal one uh you
know 20 years ago certainly
conservatives were all about local
control uh you know and certainly when
Barry Goldwater was running for
president 64 it's all about oh now let
the states decide let the subgroups
within the state decide things and now
it you know interestingly we see
um you know in these Conservative
Republican states Governor saying no no
it I get to decide
yeah that that brings me to like what
I'd would hope that you could reflect on
last which is the effects the political
effects that that we talked about at the
beginning of the ending the end of this
National Emergency
what uh because when I think about it
you know that yes there has been this
shift among
um you know conservative Red State
Governors it's it's a kind of weird
mixture of both using federalism to
fight uh for more Liberty in States but
then also uh kind of an increased
willingness to impose an ideology using
state power versus those the woke
corporations and and all that but I I
guess what what I'm when I look back and
and this your your study looks at 2020
which is kind of you know the depths of
the pan endemic we'll see what happens
when you measure 2021 and 2022 my
suspicion would be in some ways like
we're going to come out it'll it came
out of that slump but there are things
that have lingered and so is there my
biggest worry is that we have this we
had this National Emergency and it's
maybe primed the population and these
systems to accept future emergencies for
other things the flip side of that is
that I think it's awakened in a lot of
people in appreciation for Freedom that
maybe wasn't there before because then
having to live under this sudden state
of of unfreedom
what where do you fall along that
Spectrum are you optimistic uh that we
are going to reverse these Trends here
in the U.S are are you pessimistic or or
is there some mixture
that's that's a good question
um I think certainly we're not as free
today as we were in January of 2020. the
question you're really asking is at what
level how how much uh will we have
recovered and which trajectory are we
going to go I think that in economic
freedom we're going in the wrong
direction
um we can probably expect that to
continue
um one of the I'll say one of the things
that I said at the beginning of this
conversation which is that covet really
did accelerate a lot of the trends that
were already happening in the United
States and
um when you have a situation where
people are literally fearing for their
lives and seeing that the government is
not actually doing a good job at
um securing that you know that does
create incentives uh to give more power
to the to the strong man to the guy that
you know screw these institutions we're
just going to do this and it'll be done
in an arbitrary fashion which is what
what happened to a large extent so
um you know
the politics of the United States has
been transformed in the last several
years the Republican party is totally
different than it was just a few just
several years ago for that matter so is
the Democratic party and I think that
we're going to recover freedom of
movement we've already done that mostly
assembling Association we've done that
uh mostly
freedom of expression I think that's
still going to be
um going to be a tough uh issue
um rule of law I think that's still
going to be it a tough issue but there
will be a recovery and
um I don't want to give any prediction
because I tend to be an optimist
um but right now things aren't even
though they're recovering they're not
pointing in the great long-term
Direction but I do feel like there's
also a backlash against uh this
excessive power which is one of the
great things about this country
that's a great place to leave it thank
you very much Ian Vasquez nicolespie our
producer Adam Sullivan and all of you
who tuned in we will see you again next
Thursday
thank you